Welcome back everyone this will be my full
ms marvel episode 2 video there were a bunch
of easter eggs and connections to everything
in marvel phase 4 so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes
we're doing a disney plus giveaway for memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
just leave all your theories about what's going on
in the comments below careful for spoilers for the
episode if you haven't seen it yet but we'll start
at the beginning and work our way through shot by
shot talking about easter eggs and wtf moments as
we go along starting with the episode title it was
called crush which is a reference to her crush on
the comrade character from the comics and at the
end of the episode how she's emotionally crushed
metaphorically when she almost fails to save the
kid it was kind of a powers montage kind of
episode where she's still kind of learning
what's going on with the bengal and learning about
the backstory of the bengal i have a couple big
theories about what's going on but it's only two
episodes in so there are a couple left turns that
they could take with the story i explained during
my episode 1 video how they said that they're
changing her powers from the comics she's not
going to be an inhuman like she was in the comics
but there are some easter eggs to her comic
book backstory so i'll point those out as we get
through the episode this time at the beginning of
the episode they actually start with the standard
marvel studios logo with the regular fanfare like
they didn't have a special song at the beginning
but in the actual opening scene in a stark
contrast to the way she entered school last week
she enters full of confidence like she's a full
baller now because of all of her powers and they
have a record scratch moment where she bumps into
her new crush the comrade character who's playing
a transfer student senior at her school who's come
it sounds like because his mother wants him to get
close to kamala so they can steal the bengal for
themselves they're using a lot of these tropes
behind a lot of love triangles and a lot of the
bollywood references are references to the actual
plot of the series with their love triangle
because very clearly they're foreshadowing
her having a relationship with the bruno character
but there's this other bad boy character comrade
that they try to introduce and make you think
that he's a big deal when really he actually
winds up being kind of a villain from the comics
there are a couple references to this but he's not
completely evil in the comics it's really his
family that's evil and he's kind of caught in
between both worlds but in the comics he's meant
to be an inhuman just like kamala khan but because
they're changing her inhumans backstory they also
probably change his backstory too so wherever
kamala khan comes from the special dna maybe kree
dna that allows her to use the power of the bengal
his family probably has similar types of dna too
like maybe they descend from kree lineage or they
were experimented on by kree a long time ago the
funny thing about his powers in the comics too is
that his powers actually look a little bit like
what she's doing with her bangle with the energy
based powers because it's only six episodes in the
series we'll probably learn what's really going on
with his character pretty soon because you meet
his mother literally at the end of the episode
and she wants it being the person that the bengal
showed to her in her visions like it's trying to
show her big flashing warning signs like this
is what really happened but you don't totally
understand how the powers of this bengal work
yet so you don't know what's going on that's why
literally after they learn about the party that
they're going to go to they play that song bad
bad boy also later in the episode when they have
that funny lie with her older brother saying that
he's really her cousin like he's our cousin that
also might be a subtle reference to their families
having similar dna allowing both of their families
to use the bengal she makes a reference to ant-man
the wasp saying that she tried shrinking and
flying with her new powers but it didn't work
also setting up the powers montage later in the
episode when she tests out her new abilities
she also makes a real-life paul rudd joke when
she says she thinks that they had ant-man powers
because they're both charming and they look a lot
younger than they are if you don't know about that
real-life paul rudd joke everyone thinks that he
ages in reverse like he looks way younger now than
he did 20 years ago her friend of me zoe goes full
flash thompson like it's literally right out of
the spider-man movies standing ms marvel but not
knowing that she's really kamala khan the way that
flash thompson hates on peter parker but loves
spider-man eventually they do become good friends
in the comics but i think that's gonna play out
over the course of the series like it starts out
with her seeming like she actually hates kamala
khan when secretly something else is going on
and by the end she winds up being her good friend
her cousin nakia who has this big subplot in the
episode is a big part of the series doesn't have
powers in the comics she's just a normal teenager
but without realizing it she refers to her as
the budget captain marvel without knowing that
she's talking about kamala khan a reference
to her eventually taking the name ms marvel
modeling herself based on captain marvel later in
the episode when you're in her room on her dory
you can actually see a picture of her dressed
as captain marvel but with the mask on from her
comic book costume so it sounds like those are
going to be inspiration for the costume that she
creates for herself based on the comic book one
the joke about her name being night light early
on is part of her figuring out exactly what's
going on with her new powers later in the episode
there's also a person in the crowd that calls her
the night light it's just a call back to that joke
it's kind of like their version of the spider-man
night monkey joke like look it's the night monkey
they settle on calling her power hard to light but
if this does wind up being a version of the kree
nega bands from the comics the way they work is
kind of like the green lantern powers with the
power rings allowing her to turn light energy
into anything she wants also kind of turning
mental energy into physical energy like the kree
nega bands but the way the show explains how these
bands work is that the more energy they absorb via
light like the flashes from the cameras the more
powerful her abilities become and it sounds like
the bengal works in concert with her own biology
like she has to have a certain type of dna for
the bengal to work anybody can't just put it on
i explained this during my episode 1 video but
the big reason for them changing her powers to
make them work this way is so that on screen when
she's in the marvels movie with captain marvel
and monica rambeau all their powers kind of come
from the same place relatively and they look kind
of similar for example captain marvel big cosmic
battery can absorb and give off large amounts of
cosmic energy if ms marvel is fighting next to her
the bengal will absorb that light energy coming
off of captain marvel making it super powerful
making ms marvel way more powerful and because
we're talking about the captain marvel mythology
that area of the comics that's why i think that
we're getting into kee nega band's territory
here with partial kree dna when they start
testing her powers out she embiggens one of her
fists just like the comics they're trying to make
her powers look like they look in the comics just
using this completely different source from where
they come from and explain the way they worked
being a little bit different in the comics she's
literally making her body parts bigger this
time she's using light-based energy to do it
the whole thing with her not having super strength
obviously big joke on other avengers powers like
oh you're not like the hulk or thor you don't have
super strength but the reason why it works this
way is because in order for her to embiggen her
body parts and use them that way she has to form
the constructs around her entire body so like the
construct itself supports the weight of the other
larger constructs later in the episode she loses
control of her powers and you see just kind of
automatically forming that construct around her
eventually she'll get better at doing that she'll
be able to form that construct around her entire
body and do like much bigger much crazier things
the other funny thing about them doing the powers
montage on the rooftop is this will remind you of
tobey maguire's spider-man with his powers montage
on the rooftop plays out pretty much the same way
too but basically the way her powers work is
pretty much what you saw from the green lantern
movie same way that green lantern's powers work
when she says her powers feel like thoughts given
form that's literally her talking about the
powers of the kree nega bands from the comics
mental energy turned into physical energy but like
i said the way they're clarifying this like when
they have the big readout on the power coming
from her body it sounds like the bengal only
activates for people with particular dna so when
they say the power's coming from her it's really
her mental energy turned into physical energy
but it's all flowing through the bengal itself
the mobile game winds up giving her the idea to
create the platforms running across air which she
used later for the save she makes a thor asgardian
reference wondering if she's got alien dna too
bruno says maybe but she's not asgardian i'll get
into this in a second but i think this has to do
with the lineage of her family being modified
or being park kree itself like her family is
technically actually part alien when she says
there's old arabic or urdu writing on the bengal i
believe that's just foreshadowing for her learning
more about her ancient family line and how her
grandmother wound up with the bengal and her
mother back during the partition of india there
are a couple references to this during the episode
the actual partition of india that's a real life
event the british left india they had a civil war
and literally like the larger india broke into two
different countries millions of people were forced
to move and that's where modern-day pakistan and
modern-day india come from they actually used
to be a single country during the scene in the
mosque i believe that there's actually a cameo
scene from the directors here sitting up front
they set up this whole running story line with
a mystery shoe thief to keep stealing people's
shoes at their mosque that'll probably pay off
later episodes and tie in with the larger plot
then i believe when they reference the bollywood
movie bossigar that's meant to be foreshadowing
for the future plot in the series like part of
the plot for komron's character will play out in
a similar way with some kind of tragic redemption
like plays out in that movie and the ddlj movie
that they mentioned is more of a romantic comedy
bollywood movie that i think is just meant to be
a reference to bruno kamala khan's and komron's
story with their love triangle there's even a
kingo bollywood reference later from the eternals
movie don't worry i'll talk about that too
because there are a couple references to things
that they talk about during the eternals movie the
whole dance sequence when she comes back is meant
to be like a fantasy sequence of what's happening
in her head based on the dirty dancing movie also
i think when he's texting with her the camera
transitioning to the stars on her ceiling passing
through the captain marvel comic book drawings on
the wall is just another reference to her becoming
ms marvel all the captain marvel backstory that's
part of her origin especially with the kree
and the scrolls literally in outer space the
transition to the world history class textbook i
think is also foreshadowing for her learning more
about her family's history as it applies to the
backstory behind the actual bangle history written
by the victors meaning that like what you thought
wasn't actually what was going on the same way
when captain marvel was told to lie by the kree so
that she would learn about the truth of her powers
pretty much all the secrets behind kamala khan's
family's backstory the backstory behind the bengal
will have something to do with the captain marvel
character and the stuff from her movies that's why
i think it has less to do with actual inhumans
terrigen missed terrigen crystals and more to do
with what's going on with the kree in the scrolls
because this series will also be connected to the
nick fury secret invasion series that's also about
a splinter group of scrolls trying to infiltrate
the world so it's possible that kamala khan's
family maybe comron's family or their ancient
family are also part of those kree sleeper cells
because literally during spider-man far from home
telos and his wife who are pretending to be nick
fury in maria hill talk about there being kree
sleeper cells on earth also in the comics captain
marvel's mother secretly winds up being kree
all these funny awkward scenes of her losing
control of her powers at the worst possible
moment are just meant to be in the same vibe as
spider-man learning about his spider-bite powers
in funny ways we didn't really get it as much
with tom hall and spider-man because you meet
him after he's already gotten the spider bite but
you kind of saw it with tobey maguire's spider-man
and andrew garfield spider-man when bruno goes
into the counselor's office you see the hang
in there cat poster in the background that's meant
to be foreshadowing for her save at the end of the
episode when he's literally hanging in there and
she tries to save his life bruno winds up getting
into the caltech program early he's going to be
this tech based character i think that's because
with the future of her character she's going to
be doing much more cosmic stuff with her abilities
and it'll wind up helping her out create tech
that will help her in her actions as a superhero
the counselor also makes a big star wars jedi
reference lots of star wars references so
far and there's only been two episodes he also
mentions the devil wears prada later when she's
driving camaron's car he also makes a mario
kart reference saying that bowser must have
taught her how to drive because she's driving
like a maniac the person that they mentioned
sha rook khan is just a huge bollywood star
who's been in a bunch of really popular movies
but then like i said they actually reference kingo
from the eternals movie because he's been in so
many bollywood movies they don't know that he's
an eternal they just know that he's this big star
and they make a joke to kingo pretending to be
himself over the years like he pretended to be
his father his grandfather before him that's what
they mean when they're joking about their mother
their grandmothers still kind of standing the king
goes senior because they think that it's kingo's
much older father when really it's actually just
kingo pretending to be his father it would be
funny if we actually see one of kingo's movies
on the actual series but i don't know if they
actually filmed any new kingo footage for this
there might just be some posters in the background
here and there at the family dinner they do
reference more about the actual partition of india
like i said they basically explain the history
it's pretty accurate to the real world history
saying that her mother's family came to pakistan
after the partition her family is where the bengal
comes from and as far as the series is revealed so
far the bengal started with her great grandmother
and what they say is basically as a little girl
her grandmother got lost when they were boarding
the last train and as the train was leaving the
station she somehow made it on board because she
followed a trail of stars what actually happened
is it sounds like her grandmother used the power
of the bengal to basically create platforms kind
of like kamala khan did to save the boy at the
end of the episode like the same thing happened
at the end because the constructs she makes look
like a trail of stars also later in the episode
the illuminati's big illuminati reference don't
worry i'll get to that talk about all these crazy
stories that they have about her great-grandmother
who apparently disappeared after that day on the
train saying that she had all these secret lovers
people thought that she was having affairs when
really what was probably happening is she was
actually trying to be a superhero just ducking
around on the dl it'd be like j jonah jameson
creating a bunch of fake stories about peter
parker like why isn't peter parker ever around
here he must be off doing something bad when
really the reason that peter parker is never
around is because he's busy off being spiderman
trying to be a superhero so her great grandmother
was probably doing the same thing with the power
of the bengal and when they say that the great
grandmother disappeared after that day on the
train it's probably because somebody killed her
to try and take the bengal early theory is that
it's probably someone connected to comron's family
literally after her father says oh your
great-grandmother disappeared one day
right after that is when she has the vision
of cameron's mother so it's like yeah clearly
it's probably this person that's connected to the
disappearance of the great grandmother the whole
joke about her mother and father being stanza bon
jovi is because one he is from new jersey like
they're from new jersey but it also sounds like
they just fell in love with american pop culture
when her mother talks about loving captain kidd
that's also a reference to bon jovi because his
nickname is captain kidd meant to kind of dovetail
with kamala khan's love of captain marvel like
they both have their captains that they're huge
fans of in the whole thing with her mother getting
super weird every time she references what's going
on with her great grandmother's family the bengal
is probably that her mother either knows what's
really going on and doesn't want kamala to get
caught up in it because she's afraid for her life
or i think probably more likely she actually buys
in to a lot of the theories about the bad things
that they thought that their great-grandmother
might have been up to like she literally makes
it sound like she ran away from the bad rumors
behind her great-grandmother and her family when
she came to america the actual eid festival that
they go to is basically exactly what you see in
the episode it's just a yearly muslim festival
kamala khan references the illuminati which we
just saw in the 838 universe in doctor strange
2 when she's talking about the illuminati's in
the context of the episode it's just a joke that
there's this group of old wives that just gossip
and secretly influence the lives of all the rest
of the mosque then they finally pay off that post
credit scene from episode 1 with damage control
it's the same agent from spiderman no way home
this is meant to take place after the events of
spider-man no way home they were originally
created by iron man to basically clean up
superhero collateral damage but since then the
federal government has kind of taken over and
turned them into like an actual branch of the
government now they're more like the fbi the
cia they make this big joke about interrogating
zoey but clearly she doesn't know anything about
what's really going on with kamala khan eventually
she does wind up being good friends with her so i
think eventually she will try to help her and
it'll have something to do with this damage
control subplot later in the episode when you see
them go after her with the drones those actually
look like the drones from the edith device that
iron man created from spider-man far from home
like now damage control has taken the drones
and are using them for their own law enforcement
when she's actually saving the little boy at the
end she does a black widow superhero pose she's
a total poser she sees another vision of omron's
mother reaching out to her it could be something
in present day that's connected to the bengal or
the bengal could just be showing her a recording
of something that happened in the past like i
said in the comics comron's family is bad news
i think the whole idea here is that they want
the bengal but now we have two legit villains
on the show we have comrades family and we have
damage control during the end credits it's the
same comic book art from the ms marvel comics
like all these panels are comic book panels
there's also a tracksuit bros moving van yes trust
a bro van from the hawkeye series meaning there
could be some more references to that like it is
a coincidence that we see it out here but this is
jersey city it's not that far away from what was
happening during the hawkeye series if you spotted
any of the big easter eggs in the episode that
i didn't talk about during the video just write
them below in the comments and leave all your huge
theories about how you think the comrades mother
is connected to the bengal and what happened to
her great grandmother my full ms marvel episode 3
video will post next week also big obi-wan kenobi
finale next week too everyone click here for my
full obi-wan kenobi episode 5 video in easter eggs
and click here for my new loki season 2 first look
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!